would all alien civilizations
have an evolutionary process
on a planet
so like that's one of the almost it's
almost the definition of life to create
all those memories you have to
have something like a change in time
yeah and then but there has to be
selection
um that's like an efficient there's no
other way to do it no i don't well never
say never because students say that
that's the part that depresses me though
going back to like i don't know the
earlier discussion on violence and
things like and i i don't know where
somebody was tweeting about this
recently but like you know how much
stuff had to die
maybe it was you yeah ah yeah
yeah and uh
i guess
a lot of murder had to occur right so
selection means things had to be weeded
out right so well we can celebrate that
death makes way for to yeah i mean it
and also you know one of the most
interesting features of major extinction
events in the history of our planet is
how much novelty emerged immediately
after right so and of course you know a
lot of people make arguments we wouldn't
be here if the dinosaurs didn't go
extinct so
um
in some ways
we can attribute our existence to all of
that but i guess i was just wondering
sort of like if i was gonna build a
universe myself
in the most optimistic way would i
retain that feature but it does seem to
be a year you have to i mean i think
we're i think we're probably being over
um anthropomorphizing i remember
watching uh the blue i think it was the
blue planet david attenborough were
showing these seals and because of
climate change some seals were falling
off a cliff and how tragic that was i
was like
i'm saying my son
that's pretty cool look at look at those
ones down there they've obviously got
some kind of mutations some and they're
not doing that daft thing and so that
that that poor gene will be weeded out
of course at the individual level it
looks tragic and of course as human
beings have the ability to abstract and
we empathize we don't want to cause
suffering on other human beings and we
should retain that but we shouldn't look
back in time and say
you know how many butterflies
had to die
i remember making this
how many
if you think about the caterpillar
becoming the chrysalis and then the
butterfly getting out
how many if that suffering we call it
suffering if that process of pruning had
not occurred we have no butterflies so
none of the butterfly beauty in the
world without all that pruning so
pruning is required but we shouldn't
amplifies and feel sorry for the
biological entities
but because that's that seems to be a
backwards way of looking at it what we
should do is project forward and maybe
think about what values we have across
our species our ecosystem and our fellow
human beings you know you know now that
we know that animals suffer at some
level
think about humane farming when we find
that plants can in fact are conscious
and can think and have pain then we'll
do
um humane gardening
until that point we won't do it right
i like this
um
famous chemist endorses the majestic
nature of murder that's such a that's
the title
uh um i didn't say that but it came well
i just
inserted i have a hard time with it
though i think that we can put it it's
kind of
but it it's the reality of it's the
reality of it is beautiful
um you know there's an instagram account
called nature's metal
and i i keep following it on following
it because i can't handle it for
prolonged periods of time we evolve
together you die alone
yeah we evolved together well you die
alone so i you live alone too it's the
gatsby thing i don't know we evolved
together where's the together the
together is the murder the population
and the sex
and murder my my romantic vision of it
to try to make me happy sarah instead of
sad sarah
um i talk in third person when i think
very abstractly sorry um
is um you know like like this whole like
you know the like certain things can
co-exist so the universe is trying to
maximize existence but there's some
things that just
aren't
the most productive productive
trajectory together but it doesn't mean
that they don't exist on another
timeline or another chain somewhere else
like i like and maybe you would call
that like then some kind of multiverse
or things but
what am i saying
i think you can't i just you can't go
down just making stuff up no you're not
no matter
is illogical and we need we know i know
i know if you look at bacteria if you
look at virus i mean just
just the number of organisms that are
constantly like looking at bacteria
they're just dying non-stop right
slaughter right so well and this goes
back to the conversation about god i
mean like there's the whole thing about
like why is the universe enable
suffering individuals don't exist right
in individual so for this i think if you
think about life as an entity on earth
right
let's just let's just go back a second i
mean i like to i'll be ludicrous for a
second i don't exist you don't exist
right
um but you but the actions you do the
product of evolution exists right the
objects you create exist
quantitatively in the real world if you
then understand life on earth or alien
life or any life in the universe there's
this integrated entity
where you need you need cells in your
body to die otherwise you'd just get
really big
and you wouldn't be able to walk around
right so you know you do yeah yeah
yeah so yeah so i think
the patterns that persist not the
physical things and of course we you
know we have we have we place immense
values on fellow human beings and i'm
a just majestic professor does like
other individual human beings or no
you're talking in third person too i
know it happens right so death would you
say i mean because you said evolution is
a fundamental part of um
life so death is a fundamental part of
life yeah
it might right now it might not be in
the future we might hack some aspects of
death
we could and will evolve in different
ways
you